Welcome to the mini project on text learning.
I want you to think back to some of the earlier lessons in this class,
where you were identifying the author of an email based on
the words that they were using in the emails that they sent.
Now you have much more of appreciation for all the work that goes into
preprocessing text before you can feed it into a naive Bayes classifier, an SVM,
or anything like that.
We took care of all that preprocessing for
you at the beginning, but now you're going to sort of open that black box.
You're going to put all those things together yourself so
that you can start with what's effectively a raw email, and
then at the end of this mini project, you'll have output that's ready to
go straight into a supervised classification algorithm.